ha personalità e oggi faremo commerciale
molto particolare perché per 24 ore
monteremo solo cibo nero ma è questo che
cos'è questo fatto di un pancake per te
al cioccolato noi possiamo mangiare cibo
vero niente
abbiamo fatto perché hanno fatto con me
e altri devono fare in pigiama perché
altre non fare colazione quindi faremo
assieme colazione pranzo merenda signore
era però il cioccolato di lo posso
mangiare perché vero domeniche fa
challenge famosissima in america abbiamo
visto vari video in america sta
impazzando questa challans in cui per 24
ore si mangiano solo cibi di un solo
colore quindi c'erano neri gialli verdi
blu e vi ho chiesto tipo due settimane
fa che colore volevate che facessimo e
ci avete scritto tantissimi colori anche
i colori strani fucsia lilla jackson
contattare avevano deciso di iniziare
quel il nero e poi vediamo se questo
video raggiunge i 10 mila likes to
faremo un altro colore fateci sapere che
altro il colore volete che facciamo ma
ora abbiamo un sacco di bambini iniziamo
con la colazione cosa mangeremo di mero
di milano hanno lasciate un bel live ma
ti si superano i commenti che attrae
challenge volete cioccolato cioccolato
i miei video preferiti mangia felice
perché pensa che mangerà tante cose
buone ma allora con azione l'unica cosa
vera che ho trovato è questo piatto ma
il bianco è un po bianco col nero ma
questo non ero quindi torino in una
meditata per la colazione e cioè gli
oreo però siccome gli ore o normali
hanno una parte bianca dentro e quindi
non sarebbe stato valido
ho preso questione del passaggio di euro
ha detto la tesi più perfetti
altrimenti avremmo dovuto prendere il
rennes ormai è togliere la parte bianca
dentro anche più attivi vediamo un pò
troppi ferrotto roma sono sottilissimi
sacro sono migliori o normali perché
sono più grossi diamo allora è stato
super sottili sembra che dentro non si
sa niente
in realtà c'è un tipo cioccolato nero
quindi basterà non pre colazione da
assaggiare un altro non lo so ti do non
male insomma senza buoni me ci
somigliano moltissimo gli sembrano dire
normali però sono un pochino più di
cacao forse mi piacciono più questi
pertanto meno zuccherati io sono di più
questo non è mai chiamarlo il fatto che
sono più sottili più croccanti quindi
figlio di trovarli non iniziare
compostiamo bene
di mandorla come sempre sapevo che
questo video sarebbe stato
difficilissimo da filmare con vitale
certa stiamo bene il succo di frutta
perché non è nero ma possiamo bere il
succo di mela no ma no prima colazione è
un succo di uva nera cammino giornalino
nerissimo quindi questo punto è stato
potremmo bene puntiamo bene anche un po
di coca cola perché nera il caffè è
forte ma vediamo la nostra era vediamo
un po come una mera chi tutte le labbra
ma dobbiamo prima mischia così come dice
scritto oggi abbiamo giocato come sa
come fai succo d'uva gita addio 28 mag
gasato l'ha fatta la porticina ha fatto
davvero tutto
vediamo come sono troppo curiosa di
assaggiare brody by è nerissimo
[Musica]
super dolce mi aspettavo che fosse così
il dolce sembra tipo la fanta all'uva
presentano bevuto una fanta l'uva e di
benvenuto il succo d'uva
scriveteci nei commenti sembra succo
d'uva con tanto zucchero
cosa ci aggiungiamo altro best per
correlazione basta così cos'altro
co.re.ve per ora non solo queste cose mi
dispiace valute nazismo tipo nero adesso
c'è molto altro biscotto cosa ne pensano
le di questa colazione e povera mangiare
di più le ore o mi sono piaciuti un
sacco ma il succo d'uva così così e
dovremo continuare a berna tutto il
giorno adesso ci troviamo un bel caffè
possiamo bere un tè nero e tutto il
giorno nero se non volevo tenere che in
realtà lo zero nere si commentano beve
il caffè beltaine di solito la mattina
hanno fatto solo uno ne la cosa non è il
tema che non ero io odore beh se bevo
tantissima come gli inglesi
questo mi piace il tè o il caffè di
questa è la nostra colazione e tra poco
arriva il pranzo ma che cosa abbiamo
trovato per franco
vediamo cosa sono perché sono nerissimi
tra l'altro sono tipo spaghetti neri ma
in realtà questi sono noodles che
sarebbero quelli asiatici noodles di
somma ed io giapponesi e questi sono di
una volta ti staranno buoni
[Musica]
eccoci qua ecco qua i nostri spaghetti
neri di riccioli dall'impressione no è
un omaggio
siamo pronti ad assaggiarli quindi a un
po ardito voi l'appetito non sono male
sempre di montare del riso incollato
sembra proprio il riso nero molto buono
mi piace quando supertruccate prigionero
solo le maestre incollato passato
resterà non mangiare qualcosa di così
diciamo che sono anche incollati perché
non ci abbiamo messo nient'altro quindi
solo spaghetti di riso
voglio vedere io che cosa mi mangio
dall'aborto divario che cos'era comunque
non me l'aspettavo mostrano buoni
spaghettini su semplici senza niente
perché sennò avrebbe cambiato colore o
metteranno ingredienti ma non avevamo
niente di vero quindi sono così ne so
niente ma presente senza niente se non
farò salomoni sono proprio riso e sembra
di montare del riso bollito del riso
nero un pulito tutto al pc chiaro
frustra propri consigli di provarli
abbiamo qualora nostri co2 tutta
l'economia nausea sono arrivati
semplice momento di una del alcune delle
tante e meno salutari al mondo che
questa mattina avevo cominciato
benissimo dopo il succo d'uva
supernatural e e adesso andate in regalo
con la durango la dovete sapere che ogni
volta che la vita ha preparato dalla
scuola inglese il proprio piccolo
problema quindi so perché ti amo il
primo forse strano che a parole successo
che non è successo di solito fa un
primato di temi tempio voi succede
perché anche la mia vita succede sempre
secondo me la cavo che poi sono i due
nomi e molto gasata succede solo con le
belle donne super cacciavite quando vedo
il primo sorso mi viene un segno di
concorso forse è vero perché quella lì
in vetro è più un casello cosa mangeremo
per merenda secondo bene forse carciofo
lato però non è nera come la tour faccio
con la firmerà na e marrone e tutto il
resto ecco per la corona del tutto il
rogo l'area sopra una calda non c'è
quale pagano dal vostro caldo
3 che temperatura c'è da voi che tempo
c'è qualche tardissima ora il momento
della verità perché forse vale 26 forest
sicuro di sapere se c'era una cosa a
volte per te tutta nera ma questo tursi
manzo e per te lo stesso no voglio solo
quello conosciamo la liquirizia nere e
poi abbiamo preso vuole ha detto quando
pensavo che dolci si sono neri mi sono
venute subito e mentre i tour infatti è
quella che è arrotolato mi raccomando
non morsicati la madre mi raccomando non
morde le mans rotolante perché non si
muovono tantissimi atletici nei commenti
non ci si sono neri di cui forse ci
siamo dimenticati i mostaccioli ci sono
neri anche se in realtà sono marroni non
solo che l'altro il torneo così vi metto
il sondaggio qua se il video di giudici
mio arresto
andremo a fare
un video in cui mangeremo il cibo del
colore più votato qua
poi una volta che avete votato
scriveteci tutti i cibi di quel colore
nei commenti
così ci date qualche idea che tipo di
colore mi consenta anche anno fitto
verde facile però dai perlustra verdure
perché certo cosa fermato il latte mason
il the bird bird
in realtà poi non è vero e kiwi dolci ce
ne sono come i verdi verdura in val
d'agri più ridotto del rischio risulta
infatti è caduto dalla bocca
rocco modo di certo per merenda una cosa
che ti piace tantissimo è uno yogurt
vegetale di soia alla nocciola via un po
questo lo faccio grosso non è proprio
nerissimo di gioco che un eros chiarito
alemanno tutta l'umanità non mangiarli
mando tutti a dure io così luciano da
vinci che mangia tutto nero e questo ti
voleva proprio ce lo fa fare
come attività ma allora perché vitale va
pazzo per il cioccolato io voglio se
questo non è proprio il cioccolato in
un'isola di scontri a una sola cacao e
almeno zuccherato c'è questo caso budino
di cioccolato meglio zuccherato 0 era
super dolce ma dove caricare italia miss
di mangiare interesse cosi senza niente
masticare e gridano masticare sul bacino
e poi di pizza aspettato che il di
affetto di prossimo passo sarà prossimo
e ultimo era la cena
cosa abbiamo quali super mero indovinate
cos'è cos'è cos'è e 2 melanzane poi
delle olive nerissime vita restando se
non diciamo di stare troppo buie e poi
dell'amore ma che bello il fatto che
siano tutti di un colore tutti abbinati
wow
sei anni fa vedere tutto nero in tavola
iniziamo da questi fagioli neri la mia
maratona aiuto pronto a tutti e due tu
tieni marcia sarà pure più bravo ora
abbiamo dei bottoni neri in realtà tomo
cercando il riso nero sono trovato non
ho bevuto fatto vegetariano ce l'ha solo
manifesto e quindi facciamone buon
appetito non male buoni per essere una
cosa che si super semplicemente niente
sono poi mi sono solo bolliti ma non
abbiamo messo pomodoro aldo cipolla
buoni non me l'aspettavo proprio
marcatore con i fagioli che si mettono
dentro è bollito
quindi proprio di immaginarlo con la
tortilla con il riso però sul brano dei
fagioli ti mettevi commenti cuore
l'altra cosa da mangiare e nero
preferita zona sono liquirizia non ho
mai visto così quando si smette di fare
con il riso nero di fare il sushi che io
so che hai fatto ti piace tanto da
youtube
però l'ho trovato un cadeau e questo non
si formò armato che il riso nero si no
no quella vocale diventarlo verde poi
con l'avvocato di solarità sono
ristorante ma lontani i miei gol è il
primo giorno addirittura le olive in
vado pazza perché rivale mangerei
scatole non manca la regola leggevo che
non teatro quindi meglio così non tanto
perché non mi ruba questo video metà
challenge metalmark band capitale
piacciono questi video comunque devo
dire la verità in però mezzanotte magari
può scorrere melanzana al forte ma come
le mangiate questa melanzane dopo le
facciamo altro hanno torto manzo le
olive che mi mando tutto ma morello nel
confronto nero lo sai che non lo so io
ciliegie nere per uno del suo mandato 40
tribe
ma scusa dopo potremo mangiare anche il
cioccolato di stop e nero
la delibera sai cosa dipende
l'amore davvero buona altro che oliveri
dopo che cosa si basa tutta la
costituzione altrimenti bottone
mangiando solo cibo nero passista per
quale cibo nero che abbiamo mandato che
mi e piaciuto bene quello che mi è
piaciuto di battista bene qual è il
prossimo colore che volete che si chiama
marchesa challenger 24 ore ma stanno
dicendo adesso vorrei che mi stanno
dicendo adesso delle leggende il
prossimo valore sarà ben 24 ore tutto
tutto 24 maggio quindi lì significa non
vedere i nostri altri video clicca su
quella che per benitez